what have you learned now through these
four companies five projects if you've
incubated stuff you know when you look
back at this you know decade of work for
more now what do you think is at the
core of creating startups well I mean I
think being a founder the most important
thing really the kind of meta-level
important thing is to know yourself I
think most people do not spend enough
time understanding themselves and
understanding what are you good at and
what are you not good at and for the
things that you're good at how do I like
focus on those things and do more of
them and for the things you're not good
at how do I either improve or how do I
delegate those to someone else I think
most founders hit a wall because they're
doing something it starts working and
then they don't get out of their own way
you know they are they insist they think
because I created the product and it
wore it which there's a heavy dose of
survivorship bias there I am gonna like
I all my decisions are right so I want
to micromanage kind of all these other
parts of my company where I want to be
to make all these decisions or my ego is
such that I don't get out of the way of
these other people I brought into the
company to let them operate and I feel
like that's a very common problem that I
see all the time and this problem that
I've had in my life throughout my life
that I've you know kind of only you know
in the last maybe five or six years
really understood deeply so is that
self-awareness you know and identifying
your superpower yeah what's your
superpower what are you short on that
I'm a very good salesperson I think I'm
a very good hype man I think I'm very
you know so that applies to all the
sales like things so fundraising
recruiting sales you know actual sales I
think those are those are that's kind of
one of my superpowers I think I also
have a on like a very deep well of
confidence that you know myself and the
right people can build anything you set
your mind to and I think that's that
really has put me on the path to like
say oh whatever startup it is I could
figure that out see that is those are
superpowers that I think people
sometimes underestimate the value of
yeah because the ability to sell and get
people to pay attention to what you're
doing is such an amazing superpower I
share that superpower
it's like kind of why we vibe I think
it's because getting people to just even
recognize the existence of what you're
doing in such a busy world exactly
but then combining it with the blind
faith that it's all gonna work out
and don't worry exactly see I added that
skill later in life to where I just said
listen I looking back on the last one
here it's like it's always worked out so
let's not assume that it's not gonna
work out let's assume it's gonna work
out yeah right and the justin.tv
probably just burned that it's like
engineered man you have to have faith I
I always tell people you know when I was
born on Y Combinator you know I would
spend time telling every class that came
in now I would tell my group look here's
my story if we can do it
you have no excuse because this is the
stupidest idea with people who had no
skills who went through an 8-year
journey that mostly people would have
given up on and then on the back end of
it created something pretty amazing and
so you know you have to have that
confidence and you have to have that
self belief you know even if you're kind
of taking it on faith yeah and you just
surround yourself with people who are
good at the other stuff exactly this is
what people underestimate like you don't
it's good to have like the 60% capacity
to be a developer yeah then recognize
like a [ __ ] I am NOT the world-class
developer I I can hack my way through
stuff you know but that's not me
that yeah exactly right like I started
developing I was just like I don't enjoy
this I want to go talk to people about
what we're building I don't want to sit
here quietly for 12 hours you know write
code it's other people it's like they're
destroy I I actually did like I really
liked writing code but I felt like after
a while it's a much more efficient use
of time for other people to do it
mmm yes for sure tell me about your
journaling I know that you've you know
so I've been a hardcore on this
mindfulness stuff in the past year and
we saw a thing that triggered it were
you feeling anxiety were you feeling
yeah so atrium was very stressful
actually because we've grown you know we
grew this company headcount very quickly
and obviously raised a lot of money and
I think the expectations are very high
and when you have high expectations is
easy to get trapped in the expectation
feedback loop where you are worried
you're not fulfilling them and then you
are
feeling bad and then you know that's a
cycle right and so at certain point I
was like this is not good for me and
this is not sustainable and I need to
like figure out how I deal with the
external circumstances in in like
independently I make my mindset
independent of external circumstances
right and so because no matter where you
are there you can always even perceive
things as negative or positive right
like people would be like oh you already
started billion-dollar company already
it's not you know they've done so well
like why would you be stressed but
you're like oh well I made a promises
for this next one and I want to build it
to the next level etc etc and so and if
I've got through those problems there's
gonna be a new set of problems I'd ever
get through those same problems there's
gonna be a new set of problems right and
expectations and so I started looking
for ways to improve my own stability and
make my own you know mental health
independent of those external
circumstances and the things that I
first started off with like okay I'm
gonna die it better I'm gonna eat better
right so that was young thing start
eating keto which is really good for me
because I'm very carb sensitive and then
I started exercising regularly so you
know trainer shows up three times a week
make sure try to do something every day
but like have these like regular
exercise right those are kind of basics
everyone knows about but then I started
my friend of mine recommended this five
minute journal app which is like a
gratitude journal what's the name of it
five minute journal five minutes yeah
and this app very simple but amazing
it's just every day you enter in the
three things that you're gonna do that
you're grateful for that day and the
three things we're gonna do to make that
day great and then there's like an
affirmation section and I I was
sceptical actually when I heard of it
and he was telling me about it but I
thought I'll just try it for a week
because if I tried for a week it's five
minutes times seven thirty five minutes
that's not a lot of come now and after a
week I felt much happier because it
recontextualized
everything that's happening as like in
the greater context of all these good
things that are going on right and then
I actually am happy every day and if
there's like oh I have a bad meeting or
I don't know something bad happened in
the company it's like not the end of the
world and kind of you kind of remember
like you've probably experienced this
throughout your career the things that
you worry about that seem like the end
of the world you know today in a year
you're probably gonna look back on that
and think you're gonna not remember it
right or you're gonna think well that
was an experience I got through so if
you have some like positive remember
of that so you know I feel like that
recontextualizing it like that in the
present is very valuable and sure yeah
and that has made me that's another
thing that made me significantly happier
and then the last the the other thing
that I've been doing is I started
meditating every every day I've been
like doing a transcendental meditation
or just oh you're doing TM yeah yeah
yeah and so you have a guru for to get
your word I got my word right or don't
tell anybody I'm not going to my magic
word you get your magic word mantra the
mantra and I my teacher amazing teacher
and yeah but doing that and I feel like
I've just had a series of amazing days
and it feels good yeah yeah I think
anybody who's attracted to
entrepreneurship like they're gonna be a
very considered in their own head
thinking about things type person and
when you think about things like to the
extent you need to when you're the
leader of a company and $75,000,000
comes in the bank or for exact 3 million
and it's working or it's not working
your mind is going to spew a stream of
every possible permutation of what
you're experiencing and what's your job
as CEO hire the smartest people you can
find yeah and then when they can't solve
a problem they come to you yeah
congratulations
they solve the hundred easy problems and
they brought you the 12 that are just
seemingly intractable or infuriating or
anxiety-producing and then the ability
to sort of distance yourself from that
stream of just word vomit salad coming
out of your brain constantly that's what
meditation really does is it gives you
that little space absolutely you're like
oh my mind is anxious about we lost our
top person or you know we yeah we got a
competitor or whatever it is you can
just quiet it exactly having that
disconnect between all the external
circumstances that are happening but
also your own emotions and thoughts
which you don't control and then
realizing that you're just that one step
behind that you're the person who's
observing those things happening he's
very powerful and I think the more you
it's not like a light switch you can
just like flip it and you're like
internalize it it's like something you
have to practice every day
and to me that was kind of my biggest
learning of 2018 is all you know kind of
this whole package of like you can
control your own happiness I never
thought that before I actually thought
people baseline happiness it wasn't out
of their control and was completely in
the control of like external
circumstances or whatever yeah and that
is I don't that's probably the most
valuable thing I've ever learned in my
life yeah it's super power I think
that's why so many if you look at
headspace and calm we're missing calm
and amazing well I mean it was like five
years ago I had Alex to on the podcast
yeah and talk about like founders who
are underestimated yeah the number one
rule I have about investing is don't
underestimate anybody yes because how
many times do you see people who were
awkward you know I mean the video of you
reading that script was in my finest
moment if you type in awkward that's
just a founder into you know YouTube
it's in the top seven because number six
awkward founder penis yes but like
everybody's awkward at the beginning and
then I just sitting there looking at
Alex and I just thought I personally
changed the world like he's so right you
know about meditation this five years
ago and I thought about the million
dollar home page you remember he did
that project yeah and anybody who builds
product like you do would look at that
and go that is such a genius meme you
know easy to understand construct it's
almost like the perfect startup right
you could build right now the two of us
could build it in a day yeah and launch
it on the world make a million dollars
it's like that perfect it's like a
perfect scene in a movie or a perfect
hook in a song know and everybody else
looked at it as a scam
yeah but you wouldn't look at that as a
scam you think I'd like a lot raise the
idea it wasn't during that phase we were
talking about where people were just
trying different stuff and I love that
yeah and then he does calm and I was
like oh that's totally gonna be big
little did I know that Trump would
become president and send everybody to
intuit arrangements indem syndrome what
makes you happy today like when you wake
up in the morning you seem like a very
positive guy like we follow each other
on
so surely you're like you seem super
considered and happy now yeah what when
you wake up in the morning what makes
you happy when you're right in that
gradua journal what are we what do we
see an attitude Journal I mean it is the
stuff that you would expect right
I have great health of a great
relationship with my wife my family my
brothers live with you know with me and
apartments underneath mine I get to see
my family I get you know I've great
friends who have been on this journey
with for for a decade now really great
team at a trim we like is like very
independent the smarts people I could
find right who are like solving those
problems a really great opportunity like
to be in a world I think about this
every day there been a hundred billion
people who have ever walked on this
earth what percentage do you think you
are in terms of your life like you and I
are probably in that top at least 10
million maybe million in terms of
success it's a success opportunity
health you know that is something really
to consider because if you just think
about if we had been born you know 40
years ago before computers and in Sri
Lanka or Bangladesh yeah in the lower
caste like what would our lives have
been we would be sitting there like
doing some menial work yeah trying to
figure out how much food we could
accumulate for our families to survive
exactly I would have been a farmer at
any other time in history you know and
so ii mean i think about that and i'm
like what a privilege i am so lucky yeah
so amazing and so I don't know that's
that's that's one of the things I also
do negative visualization I think about
like what are the all the bad things
that could happen to me and that's a
smart one and then it's like how would I
react I would really try to visualize it
and then think what wolf you realize few
things number one you will adapt the
human mind is very powerful you'll adapt
to any circumstance yeah eventually and
then the second thing is you wake up in
your real life and you're like this is
amazing